[Aplausos]
[Música]
celebrar unos juegos olímpicos en plena
pandemia es algo así como el final del
juego de tronos
y no termina de encajar se supone que es
la gran fiesta del deporte y luego te
encuentras a las gradas vacías ya pasó
el verano pasado en tokio y está pasando
ahora mismo con los juegos olímpicos de
invierno que se están celebrando en
beijing china
[Música]
los deportes de invierno desde luego no
levantan grandes pasiones algo que sea
no sé de noruega de canadá o de
cualquier otro lugar más apropiado para
los osos polares que para la vida humana
la cuestión mis queridos amigos de
visual político es que si beijing 2022
provoca grandes titulares va a ser por
cualquier otra cosa menos por la lucha
por las medallas el régimen de sikkim
ping ha intentado reeditar el éxito de
los juegos olímpicos de verano del año
2008 de hecho la propaganda china no ha
parado de destacar que beijing es la
primera ciudad que organiza los juegos
olímpicos tanto de verano como los de
invierno 2 en 1 y es verdad todos
recordamos beijing 2018 como el momento
en el que el gigante asiático despertó y
se presentó al mundo como una gran
superpotencia económica
[Música]
el estadio del nido de pájaros se
convirtió en un icono de la nueva y
moderna china todo el éxito de imagen
que además fue acompañado del éxito
deportivo por los anfitriones si habéis
oído bien no sé si recordáis pero china
ganó más medallas de oro que nunca y por
primera vez en la historia lideró el
medallero pero mis queridos amigos de
visual político las cosas han cambiado
muchísimo desde el año 2008 atentos
con johnny winter next entrar one
pequeños que viven de piercings and on
jan steen james lentz
régimen change and energy men rights
artistas exacto el boicot anunciado por
el gobierno de eeuu ha sido secundado
por australia canadá reino unido y nueva
zelanda pero ojo porque también se
sumaron japón alemania dinamarca y
países bajos ojo hay que aclarar que
este boicot es solamente diplomático y
que en ningún caso ha supuesto la
retirada de sus deportistas pero lo más
importante es que en el último año son
muchos los países que ya han alzado la
voz denuncian los abusos de los derechos
china está cometiendo sobre la minoría
uigur pero también la represión en hong
kong y la presión que se está ejerciendo
sobre la isla de taiwán
[Música]
así que la pregunta es cómo se ha tomado
china este boicot diplomático a beijing
2022 que podemos esperar a nivel
político de estos juegos olímpicos y lo
que es más importante cómo piensa
aprovechar estos juegos el régimen
comunista de xi jinping hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
de continuar vamos a hacernos otra
pregunta cómo invierten su dinero los
españoles sí vale bien seguramente nunca
os hayáis hecho esta pregunta pero de
verdad los españoles sacamos el máximo
partido nuestros ahorros tranquilos esto
no es el clásico anuncio en el que ahora
os voy a decir cómo os podéis hacer
millonarios y ser vuestro propio jefe no
os preocupéis esto solamente es el tema
del último vídeo en si lo hubiera sabido
un vídeo en el que explicamos cuáles son
las principales tendencias de inversión
en españa que hacemos bien los españoles
que hacemos mal ya sabéis que si lo
hubiera sabido es el canal de
mutuactivos en el que colabora visual
polític donde hablamos de finanzas todo
ello por supuesto con rigor
investigación y sin el clásico flick
bait de cómo hacerte millonario os dejo
el enlace en la descripción y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
una medida simbólica
los boicots en los grandes eventos
deportivos son como las referencias
sexuales baratas en una canción de
reggaeton no pueden faltar nunca el
objetivo suele ser presionar al país
boicoteado a introducir algunos cambios
como os podéis imaginar sirven más bien
para poco pero ahí quedan los titulares
desde luego si los hicieran urban pool
sonará un maduro diríamos que son todo
un gesto populista ahora bien yo creo
que no hay nada más populista que
amenazar con hacer un boicot y luego no
llevarlo a cabo sin que entre medias
haya cambiado nada esto es exactamente
lo que pasó por ejemplo con los juegos
olímpicos de berlín en 1936 muchos
países amenazaron con no participar como
medida de protesta contra el régimen
nazi que ya empezaba a enseñar sus
formas y resulta que al final
participaron 49 países más que nunca
este entonces menos mal que luego llego
jesse owens y nos dio varias
satisfacciones
[Música]
pero después vendría la guerra fría y el
que sería el padre de todos los huecos
1980 eeuu y otros 60 países optaron por
no ir a los juegos olímpicos de moscú
extraerá una protesta contra la invasión
soviética de afganistán cuatro años
después fue el turno de la unión
soviética que junto con otros países del
bloque del este boicotearon los juegos
olímpicos de los ángeles 1984 y grace
sirvieron para los tres boicots pues
obviamente no puedo esperar un momento
porque sí que hay un boicot que tuvo
efecto hablamos de sudáfrica sudáfrica
tuvo prohibida la participación en los
grandes eventos deportivos entre 1964 y
1992 como protesta por el apartheid
podríamos decir que este fue el boicot
más exitoso de la historia y tal vez el
único que realmente ha tenido un efecto
político real el problema es que este
tipo de boicot no es algo que se vaya a
poder repetir contra un gigante como
china estamos hablando del país más
poblado del mundo y eso se traduce en
que es uno de los mercados más
importantes para todas las empresas y
para el comité olímpico internacional
hay demasiados intereses en juego
también estadounidenses porque aparte de
los deportistas que se queda sin
competir en moscú en 1980 el mayor
perjudicado de aquel boicot fue la nfc
la televisión que se había hecho con los
derechos para retransmitir los juegos en
eeuu y que perdió la friolera de 22
millones de dólares de la época
[Música]
y por eso es impensable que este boicot
contra los juegos de beijing 2022 vaya
más allá de la pura y dura' diplomacia
es más el gobierno de sillín pin ya ha
tratado de restarle importancia
asegurando atentos que los
representantes de eeuu no pueden
renunciar a una fiesta a la que no han
sido invitados
eso me ha dolido hasta mi y ojo porque
esta ha sido la respuesta más educada
porque luego está la 'u' lilian uno de
los portavoces del ministerio chino de
asuntos exteriores que cree que lo mejor
que puede hacer china para justificar lo
que sucede en xinjiang con los uigures
es pasar al ataque de eeuu se construyó
sobre el saqueo de la patria de los
indios nativos y los crímenes contra la
humanidad qué autoridad tiene para
difamar las políticas étnicas de otros
países basándose mentiras y
desinformación cuál es la agenda oculta
detrás de todos sus rumores y
difamaciones como ya estáis viendo esto
no va más allá del típico cruce de
declaraciones entre los gobiernos de los
dos países rivales al final el boicot
diplomático se quedará en una medida más
o menos simbólica al unirse otros países
mayor será el efecto negativo sobre la
imagen de china pero tampoco podemos
engañarnos y hacernos ilusiones en
primer lugar nada va a cambiar dentro
del gigante asiático al menos por un
boicot como este y sobre todo estamos
ante unos juegos olímpicos que se
celebran en plena pandemia la atención
de los medios pronto se desviará a otros
asuntos y a estas alturas ya se lo que
se estarán preguntando entonces por qué
en visual político un vídeo a este tema
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
mucho yo danés y poca nieve
beijing fue designada como sede de estos
juegos olímpicos en julio del año 2015
no sé si os acordáis de donde estabais
en ese año pero os recuerdo que en aquel
entonces donald trump solo había sido
presidente de eeuu en los simpson y
occidente todavía no mostraba tantísima
desconfianza hacia china sin embargo la
situación evidentemente ha cambiado
mucho hoy en día china cada vez genera
más desconfianza en todo el mundo y los
juegos olímpicos también para que os
hagáis una idea os lo retiró su
candidatura para estos juegos después de
ver todos los sobrecostes que habían
tenido los juegos olímpicos de invierno
en sochi 2014
de hecho la otra candidatura que
competía con beijing para estos juegos
era al martín y diréis pero cuáles son
los requisitos que pone el comité
olímpico internacional para que una
ciudad pueda celebrar los juegos
olímpicos de invierno
[Música]
a una pensará que algo fundamental es
que la ciudad anfitriona tenga nieve
verdad pues no nada de eso casi toda la
nieve en los juegos olímpicos de
invierno de beijing será falsa tal cual
como lo escucháis los juegos olímpicos
de invierno 2022 se celebran en un lugar
donde nieva menos que en londres donde
aria va menos que en almería el clima en
beijing es seco es prácticamente
desértico así que han tenido atentos han
tenido que construir un sistema de
transferencia de agua que necesita más
de 223 millones de litros de agua eso es
lo que hace falta sólo para alimentar
todos los cientos de cañones de nieve
artificial y diréis mira qué bien este
disparate tampoco sostenible pues
básicamente obedece a dos claves y la
primera como ya os podéis imaginar es
propaganda
[Música]
la principal virtud de las sedes
olímpicas de zhangjiakou y jian qing es
que se encuentran a 200 a 100 kilómetros
de beijing la capital de china a esto
hay que sumarle que algunos recintos
utilizados en los juegos de 2008 han
sido re adaptados por ejemplo el water
club que acogió la natación ahora es el
icecube para los partidos de curling que
ya sabéis que es este deporte de las
modas que mola mucho verlo el estadio
del balonmano y la gimnasia ahora es la
sede del hockey sobre hielo y al famoso
estadio de nido de pájaro acogerá las
ceremonias de apertura y de clausura y
todo esto para que pues para presumir de
que beijing es la primera ciudad en la
historia en acoger los juegos olímpicos
de verano y los de invierno esto nos
conecta directamente con la segunda
clave y es que veréis al estar tan
dispersas chinas se ha gastado más de
9.000 millones de dólares en construir
un tren de alta velocidad que une
beijing con las estaciones de esquí
cercanas arslan jacob y jian qing desde
luego que todo esto parece un enorme
derroche de yuanes ya que el esquí no es
precisamente un deporte muy popular en
china pero el régimen quiere impulsar el
desarrollo del esquí cerca de beijing y
diréis para qué pues para dar servicio a
su clase media acomodada
[Música]
china practicar el esquí por lo visto es
sinónimo de una buena posición social
seguro que os parece un objetivo tan
clasista socialmente que creéis que
estoy hablando del siglo pasado pero por
extraño que parezca en china las cosas
funcionan así y con más podéis imaginar
todo el interés de beijing es que estos
juegos sean una obra maestra de la
propaganda y están cuidando hasta el
último detalle quien advierte a los
atletas olímpicos extranjeros que no
hablen sobre política los juegos de
invierno es más el hecho de que no haya
público hará mucho más sencillo para el
régimen comunista controlar cualquier
tipo de protesta es más llama mucho la
atención que mientras en occidente ya
han vuelto los eventos deportivos con
público en china el gobierno se ha
mantenido firme en prohibir la
asistencia de espectadores a los juegos
tampoco debe extrañarnos porque es
bastante coherente con el cierre
estricto de fronteras que viene
aplicando durante toda la pandemia sea
como sea os aseguro que en estos
momentos la principal preocupación de xi
jinping es otra y diréis pero de qué
estamos hablando pues atentos
el último fracaso del xi jinping
[Música]
2022 es un año muy importante para xi
jinping en teoría debería ser el momento
de su despedida tal y como fue con los
anteriores presidentes de china como
jiang zemin y hu jintao que dejaron sus
cargos al cumplir 10 años en el poder
sin embargo mis queridos amigos de
visual política esta vez va a ser
diferente todo indica que el congreso
del partido comunista chino declarará el
próximo otoño así jinping como
presidente del país hasta pues hasta que
este señor se canse de mandar al más
puro estilo de mouse de atún por este
motivo xi jinping quiere que la
organización de estos juegos alcance la
perfección quiere que el país vuelva a
recibir los mismos elogios que cosechó
con beijing-2008 desde luego al igual
que cuando organizó aquellos juegos
olímpicos china no ha reparado en gastos
en aquel momento hace 14 años
sorprendieron al mundo y mostraron un
gran mercado para todo aquel dispuesto a
aprovecharlo pero el panorama mundial ha
cambiado y de hecho desde entonces a
principios del siglo se creía que
occidente podría dialogar con china y
que esto favorecería una mayor
liberalización y apertura del régimen
comunista ahora ya no está tan claro
desde que jim ping llegó al poder en
2012 china se ha convertido en un estado
cada vez
autoritario frente al perfil discreto de
hu jintao jinping ha desplegado una
política exterior muy agresiva y claro
el choque con occidente ha sido
inevitable sobre todo desde que donald
trump puso sus pies en la casa blanca
así que el principal problema de xi
jinping no es que beijing 2022 vaya a
ser una ruina económica porque seamos
honestos unos iguales arriba o abajo
está claro que es la menor de sus
preocupaciones su principal problema es
que los juegos van a ser también un
fracaso a nivel de propaganda porque la
mayor parte del planeta ya ve a china
con unos ojos muy distintos
primero fue la guerra comercial de
donald trump después la toma del poder
en hong kong y las tensiones con taiwán
y finalmente el coronavirus porque
recordad que china no sólo obstaculizó
las investigaciones sobre el origen del
cob y 19 sino que además ha atacado a
australia por pedir una mayor
transparencia si recordáis durante todo
el año 2020 china quiso seducir al mundo
con lo que aquí en visual político
llamábamos la diplomacia de las
mascarillas con unos resultados bastante
dudosos en 2021 china quiso repetir la
operación esta vez con la diplomacia de
la vacuna y en este caso el fracaso fue
estrepitoso
atentos en el aumento de los contagios
de kobe 19 en algunos países que usaron
vacunas chinas genera dudas sobre su
eficacia las vacunas chinas fueron de
las primeras en salir pero luego han
demostrado tener una eficacia bastante
reducida en comparación con muchas otras
opciones esto ha perjudicado
considerablemente la imagen de china en
muchos países sus empresas han perdido
muchísima credibilidad en el exterior
disparado un momento porque dentro de
china tampoco creáis que están mucho
mejor
[Música]
evergrande que es una de las principales
empresas inmobiliarias del país está en
suspensión de pagos y al borde de la
quiebra y ojo porque sus problemas de
liquidez han sacudido los cimientos de
la economía china y por si estos
problemas fueran pocos siguen ping ha
visto como en septiembre se formalizaba
la autos es decir la alianza estratégica
militar entre eeuu reino unido y
australia que tiene como objetivo
plantar cara a los intereses chinas en
la región del indo pacífico y por todo
esto estos juegos olímpicos llegan en un
momento muy delicado para xi jinping los
juegos de beijing 2008 fueron desde
luego la apuesta de ala de china pero
estos juegos de 2022 pueden convertirse
en todo el símbolo de la caída en
desgracia de china así que la pregunta
ahora es para vosotros creéis que la
presión internacional sobre china puede
provocar algún cambio en el gigante
asiático o pensáis que hubiera sido
mejor un boicot total sobre los juegos
olímpicos para no ser cómplices del
régimen comunista podeis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
político sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribirse a este canal
si aún no lo habéis hecho y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones nos ha gustado
este vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en
el próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]